once states get a footing they tend to
crowd out alternatives not just not
violently but often through quite
aggressively also I think they tend to
colonize people ideologically hi I'm
Matt Welch for recent TV I'm in Freedom
Fest in Las Vegas and I'm honored to be
joined by Gary Chartier author of
anarchy in legal order which is the
second of three books talking about sort
of philosophical matters of anarchy
that's right I wrote the conscience of
an anarchist before that and I've got
another book called radicalizing Rawls
which is also about anarchy that's
coming out later this year what is the
project of the the trifecta of the
triptych that you're doing here I'd say
think pretty foundationally about what
it means to live well and treat each
other decently and show why that is
consistent with believing we can
organize our own lives we don't need
Leviathan and you describe yourself
personally as an anarchist or you're
interested in in anarchism what is the
attraction for you
peace voluntary cooperation creativity
and the lack of uniformity and for
crusty and rigidity and you also
emphasize more left libertarianism
necessarily or left anarchism than right
anarchism is that a correct kind of a
placement yeah it's have a left we
market anarchist so they tell us what
that is
sure so that's I think a way of
suggesting that traditional cultural and
other goals of some people on the Left
can be achieved in non status voluntary
market friendly way so why is it
important to to hit that and like
explain that to the left more it is then
explained to the rider why what what's
the purpose of the emphasis I guess the
purpose of the emphasis is those of us
who take that position think that some
of those leftist goals matter concerns
let's say with racism or with war or
with workplace dignity and so on our
view that's personally important and I
guess we're just building on our own our
own personal commitments and trying to
work
out in connection with our belief that
markets are important and freedom is
important I don't know if you follow the
work of John Hite very much who's been
talking about kind of the Moral
Sentiments behind their moral theories
behind publicly but it kind of touches
on that that people are motivated in
politics kind of by what they feel their
sense of kind of revulsion or like the
other people don't have good intentions
absolutely and Heights work actually
does get cited in my most recent book in
the discussion of left and right and
what I'm trying to get at there
so what are you going to be looking to
achieve with the third and final volume
here well I actually may not be the
final body broken I've got another book
about anarchy and international
relations that I'm thinking about fairly
seriously but in the book that's coming
out later this year my goal is to say
that the philosopher John Rawls who's
often seen as a kind of Paragon of
social democratic thought you know we've
recently seen in the work of John to
mozzie can be pushed in a more classical
liberal or libertarian tradition
direction and I'm suggesting we can go
even beyond that and push him in an
anarchist direction is it important to
deal with the people who always bring
the real world objection to anarchism
which is to say there ain't no anarchism
anywhere show me the anarchist state
there's a recent attack along those
lines in lives by Michael Lyndon salon
is that a raise an important objection
then what are you kind of respond to
with I guess I'd say several things
first of all we do have historical
precedents of various kinds that I'm not
sure Lyndon mothers like ever taken
seriously for self organized society
second I think we can have a kind of
error theory that explains why we may
not see as much of that as we'd like to
given the good I think reasons grounded
in solid economics and social psychology
for why we might expect to in particular
I think once states get a footing they
tend to crowd out alternative not just
not violently but often quite
aggressively also I think they tend to
colonize people ideologically and it's
very hard for people in people's
imaginations sometimes I think to
encompass the possibility of a radically
different alternatives do you feel like
there's more intellectual space for
discussions of anarchism now than 5 10
15 years ago
what I certainly think is that we've got
a culture in which there's increasing
cynicism about the political class and
increasing openness to radical
alternatives generally so yeah I do
think there is some of that that's great
on that positive notes for recent TV
with Gary Chartier
I am Matt Welch thank you